hello and welcome to a new edition
of las vegas spanish side of health to
natalia bad had today we kick off
our weekend with a new
song by former
las vegas resident jennifer lopez
[Music]
the new song from  yale together with
alejandro is called cambia el paso and it is
available on all music platforms
including youtube well and the
music continues to arrive in las vegas and
this time with a great announcement
by one of the musical icons
by the  dear boy bands ella
mclean and cordial from the backstreet boys
along with roy fashion from nsync and one
amores from voice are also getting
together for diaz preparing no new
projects coming to blessings on
this august last month i sat down
exclusively with her to talk
about this
de sabina walkers my friends
efe
and could be in las vegas'
from august 19 to 22 tickets for this
show go on sale on july 10 in
the morning  at ticketmaster.com when we
now change the subject and talk about
another kind of entertainment and that is that
the opinion show will take the
stage again within the cosmopolitan after
a 15-month hiatus due to the
pandemic the first show will take place on
September 24 tickets for that  event
are already available
well and if you prefer to enjoy
local entertainment in the open air
mandalay bay offers you its series of
concerts on the beach dwight yoakam will
perform this friday july 9
while on august 28 the group
caifanes will take the stage and on the 18
september the bronco group will celebrate the
day of mexican independence to
buy your station and the complete list
of artists visit mandalay bay
dotcom
well what did i do you are trying to
maximize your fun but without having
to spend a lot of money well here is
a solution the series of  concerts down
and blocks by freeman suite is already in
full effect with free shows
on weekends  dwyane wade languages
will rather be presented on saturday july 17
steven adler from guns and roses on
august 21 and twitters down on september 5
obviously you can find the
full list of artists at
vegas experience dotcom well and this
friday the star bruno mars  will be
performing at the park in bien with two
shows on friday and saturday and two other
shows on july 23 and 24 tickets for
this weekend and they are sold out but
you can still get it for the other
shows at the end of the month just visit
ticketmaster.  com
when it was time to laugh non-stop
because after this pandemic I think we
all know that we need
a laugh or two and what better way to
do it than with the geniuses of
comedy or that soft hammer and this
weekend the comedian  chelsea handler
will take the mirage iii stage at the end
of the month this comedian to go
through las vegas
yes
[Laughter]
well you can see gabriel iglesias on the
22nd, 23rd and 24th that's how he comes  diante added
two dates due to high
fan demand you will also see davis page
weiser george lopez and many
more comedians and will also be performing on
state air syrup this summer for a
complete list of all
comedians from this event and to  buy
your tickets visit mirage dotcom
well here is your las
vegas edition in spanish see you next
week
greets you natalia balseiro
[Music]